The Joe Rogan experience,
I'll be all right.
I'm the book's called
the disaster diaries,
how I learned to stop worrying
and love the apocalypse and uh,
it's really fucking interesting stuff man.
And you went,
you went really deep with this.
You covered so many aspects of the whole
idea of survival and the whole idea of
like really chaos situations
and controlling your
adrenaline and relaxing and
how most people really have no idea
that like when the shit hits the fan,
most people are just literally
going to like shut off.
Yeah.
They're going to shit
their pants and shut off.
And that is a much more
common reaction than not.
Totally.
Yeah.
So interesting to see that.
Like,
you know,
a lot of people don't
know what they don't know.
You know what I mean?
And that's,
that was kind of.
So one of the major,
you know,
sort of things I took from
this book was what stress does,
you know,
you and I know you've been in the fight
game for a long time and I've written
about the fighter's mind and
stuff and I was shocked at how,
you know,
the Cooper's color code wasn't
talked about in the fight game.
You know what I mean?
Which you know,
it's a shooting thing.
Explain the Cooper school,
consumed the book,
the Cooper's color code,
which anybody who does any
shooting will know about but,
but it's basically Jeff Cooper was a
very well known farms instructor in the
sixties and he came up with this color
code about your sort of alertness level
and you know,
white,
you're at home kind of off or listening
to music or watching TV and then yellow
you're on the street and
a orange or you know,
you sort of seeing maybe possible
danger and then read you're fighting.
And that was how he sort of quantified it.
And then the Marine Corps
later come up with black,
which was the catastrophic
failure of your mind basically.
Like the total breakdown.
And it was just so interesting to sort of,
you know,
I've been hearing about this anecdotally
and I'd seen it with fighters,
um,
you know,
guys freezing,
just doing dumb shit over and over again,
you know,
it's not working,
but they can't stop and they're
getting punched in the face.
So that's definitely
not helping them here.
But you know,
the fact that,
I mean,
I'm sure some of these
trainers knew about it,
but nobody had mentioned,
you know,
there's this huge raft of data
and research that's been done on,
on,
on stress and what it does to your body.
And,
and,
uh,
it wasn't really being
utilized in the fight game,
but you had Kimbo in fucking side control.
You work to get it.
You got it.
You were in a dominant position.
He was tired and they
could you back up bitches.
We did a video interview,
you know,
everyone's on the other line.
I've just finished training.
So I'm on the phone and one no one was
asking me any questions and I thought,
yeah,
I'm just the Guy Kimball to be so.
And then the,
someone asked a question,
they said this is how he
was holding the phone,
the Asco,
each of the questions that I,
I just,
uh,
I,
I did emphasis there just in
case you couldn't visualize it.
And they said to him,
what would you do with James Thompson one?
And he said,
I'd hung myself.
And I thought,
wow,
that's the dumbest motherfucker
in the history of MMA productions.
The,
the idea that you have one guy,
that's the most important thing,
right?
Banked everything on him winning.
So stupid eggs,
buses.
If you kicked that guy's ass,
it would have been awesome if they
left you in side control a little bit.
An awesome.
Just like it was awesome
for him when he won,
it would have been awesome for you.
Then you know,
you gotta let the Guy who's
supposed to win win win.
There's a lot of fights where the
referee errs on the side of caution and
protects the fighter.
And in a case like yours,
you feel like you were denied
an opportunity because of that,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
what I was saying before,
so I started fumbling,
but the guy I was backstage and it
just happened and I'm Gary Shaw.
Some fucking.
Yeah.
Carla though.
They call them scholar.
What seems like a nice guy with a fucking.
What was the dollar sign?
Fucking.
Yeah.
It was a chain of dark side chain.
A Scala.
Yeah.
It's clever.
Well he grew up with the rich dad and he,
you know,
it's an interesting way to live your life,
but he came up to me and he said,
you've got to go to the hospital.
You've got to the hospital now.
I know you got to go to the hospital.
Yeah.
Okay.
I turned to him and I said,
yeah,
I said Y'all,
but it turned away or you know,
because there was a lot going on.
So he didn't hear me.
Then he turned back and went,
you have to go to the hospital
now I'm taking you now and I'm,
you really want me to go
to the hospital right?
Too much.
So then I went to the press conference
instead and as I walked into the patch
conference,
go shoulders going,
we've just have to take James
Thompson to the hospital,
the
breathing,
someone caught into it and I was
drinking a drink and I think some say,
Oh,
here's the legit issue for real.
A woman like Jodie foster can come out
of the closet and still play someone's
wife.
No problem.
No one has a problem with it.
If Tom Cruise,
and I'm not saying Tom Cruise's gay,
but if Tom Cruise was gay and he
came out of the closet and um,
then wanted to do a movie where he
was making out with the chairs over,
it's over.
That's,
that's reality.
I mean,
I,
I believe,
I mean,
I shouldn't say it's reality because I'm
basing it on my own personal feelings
of how it would go down.
It might go down differently,
but I think that the people
that do polling for politicians
and stuff like that,
I mean,
you'd be amazed at how
irrational voters are.
How,
how,
how finding out.
One little thing about somebody's
past can really sway an election.
So people are very,
you know,
for the most part,
people are pretty conservative
in their ideologies.
It doesn't seem to be an issue
when you're women that are out.
It's like we don't really have that
much of a problem with us is not.
There's no like there's going to trace
trace and I really think it's Ah,
you're bumping muffs and you're
making out a neediness to cock
nude.
Yeah.
So there's also the stigma
of disease and all that.
So that comes with it too,
right?
With the gay side,
what if they're just in
a jerking off each other?
It's completely different.
That's staring each other in the eye.
They look away.
I'll look it away.
What are you worried about
for a second as a goof?
I'm gonna jerk it off.
I've been shaving around my dick because
they say it makes my dick look bigger,
but I'm not convinced.
Can you give me an opinion?
I want you to be objective here.
Let me give it a look.
I'd give it a look.
I don't think it looks good.
That looks a lot bigger.
I'm telling you it doesn't look.
Can I be honest with you?
It doesn't even live there.
You can choke you with this.
You look like you should
have a hole right now.
I'm just suck it and it
wouldn't even feel bad.
It would just go all
the way in your mouth.
I mean,
I bet would even try to right now.
But when they to go out,
you mean you don't know?
You could feel it.
We need to try.
You need to do another
Mikey and Tony in the base.
What was the characters names to remember?
I'm Mikey.
One of them was Mikey.
It was the mom.
Who is Kelly?
Kirsten.
She was great when
I was involved in boxing.
Some of the best fights I
ever saw were in the gym.
Oh yeah.
Oh hell yeah.
One day.
One day I saw a
livingstone bramble and Roger Mayweather.
Oh,
fucking go at it.
A fucking gym in Vegas.
Yeah,
another time.
Wow.
One of the gems because.
Because we all worked together.
I worked with mayweather.
I worked with Nick,
one kick,
'em floyd when floyd was first coming.
I mean,
we all work together in these gems,
you know,
and uh,
one time there was this dude,
he was a heavyweight,
his name is tracy and him and Roger
May with her fucking got into it.
He was,
tracy was a young heavyweight,
24 year old kid,
heavyweight and Roger was
fucking 1:47 in his forties.
She's like,
what you say motherfuckers is done at
the fucking gate into a back and forth.
I go,
Oh shit,
here we go.
And they got into the fucking
ring and started fighting in.
Uh,
yeah,
they started fucking fighting and at
the end of the round when the bell went
off,
Tracy tried to stop and Roger
fucking lit him up and he goes,
no rounds,
motherfucker no rounds.
So they just kept fighting straight
fucking through until fucking tracy quit.
Oh my God.
Roger fucking whooped his ass
and he fucking quit forties.
Yeah.
And then,
and then when he quit,
roger hit them another eight,
nine times after he fucking quit.
And he was basically like,
don't ever fucking mouth off to me in
this gym at 1:47 pound 40 year olds.
But Roger May Black Mamba.
Yup.
You know,
a lot of people don't know Roger.
You know a lot of people.
Everybody knows floyd.
But Roger,
his uncle in his time
was a bad motherfucker.
He had a piston right hand,
he had a nasty jab and he would
fucking slam that right hand in.
He was a bad dude for many a year.
I've seen some crazy shit
happen in fucking boxing gyms,
man.
Crazy shit.
That's incredible.
Cool.